so the number one thing that correlates
with male suicide is not depression and
this is super scary most of theal men
that I work with their mind isn't
malfunctioning they genuinely have a
life that is no longer worth living
they're looking at things and
objectively realizing that there's no
way out of the situation so they turn to
according to the World Health
Organization roughly 800,000 people
commit suicide every year along with
many more suicide attempts suicide is
the highest leading cause of death for
people 15 to 29 years old second highest
among ages 15 to 34 and third highest
among ages 10 to 14 at the age of 10 I
announced the Thanksgiving dinner table
that I was going myself one day I didn't
believe that anybody would care if I was
gone I didn't think anybody would even
notice I remember thinking that my kids
would be better off if I wasn't here I
think I just kind of wanted all of the
voices in my head to go away I was angry
and depressed total darkness felt
desperate you should just be dead you're
by yourself I was alone Nobody Loves You
Came Crashing Down just wanted a way
[Music]
out all right everyone welcome to
another episode of LED live thank you
for being here and giving us another
portion of your time we're grateful for
supporters like you who watch and just
keep us going and Inspire us every week
to keep doing this show today we have
Rob Decker in the house and if you don't
know Rob Rob has been featured on bigger
platforms from this one for sure like
700 Club he has a pretty incredible
testimony when it comes to addiction and
suicide and those kind of things so
we're going to talk about that today
thank you for being here also we have
Mikey you might remember Mikey Once Upon
a Time was working here with us so
Mikey's on the show today and we're
going to delve into your life a little
bit and some of the implications of that
and hopefully Inspire and encourage
people on a better path yeah most
definitely we want to be able to use
these stories to point the way to Christ
and amen you know a lot of times uh a
lot of these topics can be really hard
you know um I think a lot of times the
church itself has a hard time addressing
these things and so people are showing
up and um they're not having some hard
questions answered and so I hope that
possibly by me sharing this someone will
hear thems in my story and then you know
find a way out so yeah amen yeah so all
right so where where does this
start or a good beginning point you like
raised in a Christian home or oh not at
all I was baptized Catholic I mean yeah
we were as a baby as a baby I was I've
seen pictures of it I I don't think that
we it was a lifestyle that we followed
whatsoever I I think the only part of
that was the fear of God right right God
Is Watching don't use God's name in I
don't want my baby to go to hell
yeah yeah all that kind of stuff but I
mean ultimately how it all began for me
was um you know at a very very young age
um I my mom met my dad in an apartment
complex they were living next to each my
mom was a runaway she had been through
her own hard life she had been raped and
beaten and um and then she got pregnant
with me and then she was encouraged to
have an abortion and she refused to have
an abortion the St was trying to take
you out in the beginning oh back's been
against the wall for a real long time
and um and that relationship didn't work
out so my mom gets pregnant right and
that relationship doesn't work out and
then 6 months after I'm born my mom
meets the guy that I'm going to call Dad
and um they were out on the beach and
mom was strolling me and my dad who I
thought was dad you know um he met my
mom and and I remember in kindergarten I
came home and I had a a plaque or a
diploma saying that I had graduated and
it had his last name on it and that's
when they sat me down to tell me that
that that he wasn't my biological father
okay um I found out at 12 you found out
at 12 I I think and it doesn't number on
you because in that moment you're like
well you're not my real dad and and you
know and then where is my real dad and
there's this whole level of uh of
confusion and rejection I suppose
and um dude it's crazy my first real God
experience was leaving that conversation
walking down the street and Vivid
vividly I see I still see it like I was
looking down at the concrete and I was
like it's okay cuz God is my father wow
like that's deep for a kid well yeah
well you know and all hindsight 2020 I
get to recognize those moments where for
the longest time I'm sure I forgot all
about that kind of stuff but over the
next few years you know the alcohol the
the cops showing up at the house the
fights um just being surrounded about
around violence and Chaos all the time
your self medicating oh this is before
this is this is the very right early
stages of of that development um by the
time I was 8 years old I was by a
neighborhood kid
um and it wasn't that wasn't something I
could share with my father couldn't tell
my dad um what had happened to me I mean
why yeah he was just a hard dude you
know he was a heavy drinker Marine you
know very alpha male very you know um
and to to to present that to him would
be a sign of I did something wrong or a
weakness or a reflection on him right
because the kid's father and my dad were
actually friends oh
yeah yikes yeah so that happened at 8
and I kept that to myself um by the time
I was 10 I would sneak around the house
and I I found my dad's bash um you know
what age 10 10 and I'm you know I'm 46
now so you know it wasn't pulling up
cell phones and DVDs when I was growing
up you know it was vhs's and pl
Penthouse and playboys and all that kind
of stuff and and a lot of uh people that
get involved with obiously I mean not a
lot but some people have pass those
sexual abuse I would say most all you
said all I would say most all I I would
say so I currently work with individuals
that have like sexual addictions or any
kind of
addiction um a lot of them heavy into
porn and and being promiscuous they were
all pretty much sexually assaulted on
some level at some point you know um so
I see a lot of that kind of stuff so um
so 10 years old I started delving really
into um I remember becoming a freshman
in high school I'm probably about 14 14
years old and I fell in love for the
first time found found girl fell in love
and you know just seeking right you're
just you wanting to be wanted and and I
I found this young lady well her parents
had left town and uh her dad's best
friend was watching us or babysitting or
teenage sitting or whatever you do at
that point and um he bought us alcohol
and up to this point yeah up to this
point well in up until this point like
that stuff was around me all the time
but there was no driver desire for me to
really do it would her parents have ever
approved of that oh no so this friend of
the parents is buying the 14-year-old
boyfriend he had a motive Dad's friend
he had a motive and so
and I remember zema if anyone remembers
zema zema grenadine so we'd put
grenadine in zema and then champagne so
you know hindsight 2020 you look back
and was like dude he was giving us
fruitful drinks because he wanted us as
kids to enjoy it right I mean how
predatory is that dude you know but I I
witnessed um him having his way with her
thank you yeah I was trying to really
yeah I having his way with me right
there and this was my first girlfriend
he just decided to do it right in front
of you yeah he got us really drunk and
then he totally uh Abus that situation
and wow so you have to understand that
like leading up to this point so I've
been right I've gotten into my very
first girlfriend like this has happened
and I didn't have this amazing
relationship with my mom or my sister so
I have a little sister it was my dad's
daughter so my step right and she was
always treated a little bit different
than and I was treated and Mom you know
Mom she did her best to protect me the
best she knew how but to me it always
felt like she was pushing me away kind
of thing yeah again looking back on it
she was only trying to protect me how
did you and your girlfriend respond to
that happening because I'm sure there
was like well we weren't supposed to be
drinking we can't say that or I mean did
anything get said about it no no nothing
happened I mean we even hung out with
that guy the very next day oh my
goodness and I was over yeah and and and
he was like he was brutal toward me too
I remember we were out there by uh Santa
Cruz or whatever cuz I'm from Northern
California I remember taking my hat off
my head and throwing it in the water
like now he wants to bully me on top of
like what you just did you know what I'm
saying so um yeah with all that being
said it's just like you know that was
the first time I ever drank and that
happened but also I
realized that being under the
influence I didn't have to think about
all the problems at home I didn't have
to think about the fights and the
arguing and getting grounded
in um the rejection the neglect the
isolation you know all of it um it
actually felt really good and I think
that's what catapulted me into wanting
to drink and then naturally shortly
after that came the drug use because now
I'm in high school and that's and that's
available yeah totally it's totally and
then you know we're a bunch of Street
kids I mean most of us come from broken
homes we all live on very diverse group
of kids like you know you're going to
have every race and culture within our
group you know I mean at the time it was
just like there was no such thing is
racism to us it's like we made fun of
each other just to yeah so you're in
Santa Cruz I was in San Jose Campbell
area Jose um Santa Cruz wasn't too far
from where we were at so yeah I grew up
in a small town called Campbell which
was right next to San Jose California
how far from the beach probably 40
minutes 30 40 minutes from Santa Cruz so
we weren't too far from not too far from
the beach yeah but you kind of grow up
if you grow up near the beach you kind
of grow up in Beach culture culture lots
of I was I was wondering how much the
surfer skater so that would be more
skater for us it was a huge we had like
a lot of skaters in our area cuz I think
for us at that age Santa Cruz is still
far enough
like for us as adults it's drive down
the street almost right but as kids you
know you're isolated to your little
small community and it was you know
surrounded by very lowincome yeah
communities and so so I was 14 the first
time I drank in smoke like you I fell in
love with it like this is what I've been
looking for I don't have to yes feel or
think or anything well I'm pretty sure
our recovery days dates yeah they're the
same year man like New Year 2013 for me
so January 8th 2013 so you got a week
jump on me yeah crazy yeah so same same
beginnings of our our life and same year
that we got free so you stuck with your
girlfriend for a while yeah I mean it's
just what you do I guess I mean as a kid
that's just always but it created quite
some dysfunction on me cuz then I you
know I I got a lot of attention in high
school so I took advant anage of that
attention and I would run to any girl
that gave me attention and and you know
even within our friend group my
girlfriend's friends I was like hooking
up with them behind her back but would I
ever stand for that if she did that to
me probably not right like so were you
introducing them to all the things you'd
been introduced to substances or were
they already kind of there
anyway I think with them I think I was
the one that really delved into that I
didn't encourage it as as much as I
wanted to engage in certain activities
with them for my own self-gratification
and the need to feel wanted you know um
I think there was a part of it that was
a Chase and an excitement of doing
things I shouldn't be doing especially
chasing your your girlfriend's friends
um but there was also that underlying of
wanting to be wanted and I think that
was part of it but just like s or
anything else it's like or alcohol or
drugs like you you need more and you
need more and you need more and and then
where you at by the end of it you know
and so still need more you do and you
know in high school man by the time I
was 16 17 I was already a full-blown
alcoholic and you know smoking weed all
the time and you know and I started
getting really um destructive I was
getting in a lot of fights you know um I
was a pretty passive for a very long
time but it got to a point where I just
got tired of being passive you know and
I just started fighting and I remember
um man sitting in class drawing pictures
of of a guy with his head yeah I can
identify that yeah and it was FTW you
remember FTW yeah and that was kind of
like my Mantra at that point and and
then I showed up at the um a drive-in
one time and God got a fight with some
guy at the driving and heing out on me
and pointed at me yeah real real stuff
but did did you in that moment say just
do it cuz you were depressed anyways oh
you're on to something I encouraged him
to pull the trigger seriously he didn't
I 100% I I don't think he was expecting
that right he wasn't expecting he was
like he was expecting to shut me up yeah
he thought he had the power yeah he
thought he had the power and I took that
away from him when I said go ahead cuz
at that point it's like I have nothing
to lose bro you know there's there's a
bunch of people here I mean and all the
girls that we came with to the drive
they were crying and screaming like Rob
stop it you know knock it off and I'm
just and the police end up showing up
and and then I end up uh fighting five
cops um wait when they arrive yeah what
yeah well so one of the cops tried to
calm me down but he came from behind me
and my response was to reaction yeah was
very reactive what's crazy is that that
is the Behavior I saw in my house
growing up I remember watching my father
take out five cops at one time and now I
was becoming the man that I was
despising in my teenage years did you
have PTSD maybe that's why you were just
a fight or flight
situation well you know I think part of
it was being under the influence a lot
of it was a lot of the trauma that was
in my life I you know it wasn't until I
was much older that I could start to
identify um the unresolved trauma
that took place in my life you know and
and then when I was a teenager I met my
biological father and so my my dad had
left home and um you know my mom thought
it'd be a good idea for me to meet my
biological father and I'm at school all
day and I'm excited I'm like does this
guy look like me does he talk like me
like you know what's it going to be like
and I walk in to my house and he smoking
meth pipe this is my first like your
first impression of
I'm like Mom you got to make better
choices but but I will say this at that
point in my life again that was so
normal I mean I was I walked in on my
parents doing like everyone around us
did my sister
was um she would come home bloody she
was selling all of her boyfriends were
selling an on we had um white pride sons
of Samoa noros Crips all at my house at
different times like this was at my
house so I was very exposed to a lot of
different kind of life styles so the
chaos was extremely normal for me but
then you get into my 20s and it's just I
have to be drunk every single night I
have to be high you know I I
met all of it you know and I'm just
finding new creative ways to check out
from
reality um and that was my 20s and to be
honest with you every time people ask me
about my 20s it's like well I remember
very little of my 20s I just know that
every job that I ever worked I got fired
from and it was never from my
performance cuz I've always been kind of
this overachiever go-getter guy right um
very performance driven it was always
the the drug testing not even the
testing it was the partying outside
where the people got to see me for who I
was so on the outside I was this hyper
charismatic engaging fun you know loving
individual until drugs and alcohol hit
my system and you became violent yeah
very violent um extremely violent um or
you know I'd break down in tears around
people that I you know were close to me
emotionally unstable oh super I mean I
was diagnosed at one point after my
attempt is being bipolar they they
diagnosed me with that but
leading up to that point you know at 29
I met a young lady and uh we got into a
relationship and it got aggressive
really early so I left the relationship
and when I left I actually was invited
to a Bible study where um at this point
in my life I was homeless I was selling
steroids human growth hormone I was
doing
alcohol all that stuff and and
living couch to couch man and I remember
one of my buddies that I used to work
with kept encouraging me to go to um a
Bible study and at this point like I'm
like I have nothing going for me like
was this buddy doing the same stuff you
were no he was straight he was a
Christian yeah he was he was yeah super
straight up I'm just curious cuz you're
good I when I first became a Christian I
was still living that lifestyle well I
did too I mean I I got saved and ran
right back to it right so you know I I
go into this room I'm in California it's
a hot day and air conditioned room and
these dudes are like you ready to accept
Jesus they just did a you know Bible
study and I'm like okay you know like
yeah let's do this Jesus thing right and
all of a sudden like they're praying
over me and I start shaking and I'm like
I'm have nothing to worry about right
there's nothing nothing going on up here
you know um which was pretty common for
me
right um and and then I start breaking
out in a sweat I'm breaking out in a
sweat and something Supernatural
happened that
day but immediately I went back into my
old way of living and then the young
lady that I had broken up with um we
found out she was escorting so of course
one of my buddies was on the internet
wow doing his thing and um it was back
when Craigslist if you remember
Craigslist they could do the whole
escort thing right well my buddy had
found her on there and was like yo Rob
such and such she's doing this and and I
was heartbroken and I just accepted
Jesus in my life and I was moving toward
that I mean trust me it was far from
perfect right you know um and I just
felt like it was my place to go in and
stop her from that lifestyle so
initially that's what kind of happened
is we were slowing down that lifestyle
um she had one last job or John or
whatever they call it right and she goes
out to Hawaii and um she calls me from
Hawaii and she tells tells me about some
things that had happened and it was
everything short of he beat me yeah it
was everything short of that she sent me
some pictures from the phone of black
eyes and all this kind of stuff and so
the deal was when she got back we were
going to like really go on the straight
and arrow with with everything right
we're just going to work this whole
thing out and then she picked me up from
the airport I was drinking that day and
uh we went to the liquor store went back
to her place and um started getting into
a conversation and it just was an
unsavory convers ation on top of the
whole new Jesus thing for me I'd been
drinking we had already been in some
trouble together you know with the
aggressive behavior all of it you know
and I was just so overwhelmed I know
that she was and attacked um in Hawaii
and that was like a that was an overload
for me and so I went downstairs to uh
rested off and I woke up to a banging at
the door and I hear oh open up we know
you're in there Santa Clara Police like
man she comes downstairs and I asked her
what happened and she looks at me and
she says I called the cops and told them
that you tried to kill me what who
you're the one that's trying to save her
and help her man that's toxic
relationship yeah but I ran back to it
you know it's it was crazy to to get
saved and then she shows up back in my
life you know I mean I made a conscious
decision to go back to it so I accept
responsibility 100% I mean do they
believe her word over yours or how is
that yeah so in that moment I was like I
just can't do this anymore you know and
I had already struggled with the
thoughts of suicide um when I was really
little my buddy and I we used to cut our
our wrists we used to cut our arms um he
came from a really really tough
childhood as well his dad was really
rough too and so that was something him
and I would do together and and that
moment I just realized like I just can't
live this life anymore I can't do this I
can't walk it out like this anymore and
I turned around and read ran head first
through a third story Loft window um you
know with all intentions of breaking my
my neck and killing myself and just
ending the whole
situation and um my foot clipped an
awning changed my fall and I severed my
L2 lower back um vertebrae uh shattered
my left arm broke my right wrist and I
collapsed my left lung and it never
knocked me out it never did no you felt
all the pain all of it it was and I
could barely breathe and that was the
worst part and I remember clear's day
looking up at that broken window and
saying God why did you let me live yeah
went to the
hospital um 10hour
surgery and detective show up throw
cuffs on on me hit me with a million
dollar
Bond and attempt is what we're getting
you with murder so you're you're about
the worst day of your life yeah right
there yeah
um but you know the Lord showed up the
Lord showed up in in in the hospital I
remember um so I had 24-hour
surveillance they Shackled me to the bed
cuz your broken arm I'm a Flight Risk
right first of all can't even move first
of all flying didn't work for me so I'm
flight RIS right it doesn't work at all
right but like what way to kick a dead
horse you know um so they shackle me and
I have 24-hour surveillance and one of
the cops is grilling me super hard and
he's just like you know you're going to
go to prison and you know the brothers
in prison are going to do this to you
and and like man he was giving it to me
and and I broke down like I just start
crying and a nurse came in to calm me
down cuz I went through a bunch of blood
transfusions and M you know she's like I
can't have your heart rate like that at
all you know and um as she's walking out
the young lady in a disguise she got her
hair done and she was wearing
sunglasses and she has an envelope in
her hand and she's with her sister and
um the cop looks at me and something
just shifts in that moment and he goes
is that who I think that is and I was
like it is he goes yeah this doesn't
make sense so that lady who accused you
of her her shows up Hospital shows up in
Disguise in Disguise so she had gotten a
weave right cuz she normally had short
hair so she got it's like she accuses me
and then goes and gets all done and and
whatever and why was she why did she
show up uh to give me a restraining
order for my understanding that was what
was in the envelope I guess yeah I I
never saw her after that but but the the
the the cop his his demeanor just
shifted completely he knows what's up
yeah he I mean and you know and I'm glad
cuz he wasn't very nice to me so all in
a bad space guys and um go ahead I
wanted to back up just a little bit yes
when you launched yourself out the third
story yeah that moment you're making
that decision are you high are you sober
I I was under the influence a little bit
crazy um when I was young I was told
that I'd be in dead or in prison by the
time I was 30 true story this took place
eight day days after my 29th
birthday so as a parent because I have
kids now and this came from a parent you
have to be careful the things that you
say to your kids be careful what you
speak into your children because that
almost came to pass for me I had prison
at the front door and I had death on the
other side of that window and I made
made the choice like I'm just not going
to live this life I mean I was totally
betrayed in that moment like how could
you even that's not even my kind of I
mean I'm not the greatest guy in the
world I make a lot of bad choices but
that is definitely not something I would
have ever executed you know and so yeah
so she comes to serve the restraining
order does she actually give it to you
no no no the guy the cop escorts her out
he's just like that doesn't make sense
he takes her walks out and um he doesn't
question or anything oh I don't maybe
but he just it didn't make sense to him
which was totally cool with me you know
she she shouldn't have been there you
know it's just like it don't it's like
insult to injury you know um but later
that night or the next night I just
remember laying in bed cuz you know I'm
brok into pieces and I went from being
like a a bodybuilder I was a bodybuilder
and an athlete um you know I'm I'm I'm
laying in in bed just broke into pieces
Shackled to a bed and I'm asking the
Lord you I'm still fresh in the faith
and I'm asking the Lord like what
happens what do we do from here you know
and all of a sudden it crazy because
this this happened to me twice in my
life and I'll share that that next is um
in the midst of like all this Brokenness
I had diloted and morphine going
straight into my neck I mean I had like
the most powerful pain medication I
could L move I mean it hurt it just
everything hurt and in this moment it
was this overwhelming piece that just
kind of draped over me and with all
Clarity like I heard it was my voice but
it wasn't me that the charges will be
dropped your bills will be paid and you
will walk again amazing and I woke up
and the lights the chaos the noises the
air machine the you know met all of it
it was all back and I was in deep deep
deep pain again well one of the cops
that comes in to see me says Hey Decker
um they're going to drop the charges wow
like what yeah one down so they come in
take you know they drop the charges they
take the the Cuffs off well you know I
was a um I was basically arrested in the
hospital right you know I've sh Shackled
Shackled to the bed
and so I didn't get visitors so my mom
shows up my mom's talking to the doctor
and she's breaking down crying and um
you know I ask my mom when she walks in
the room like what what's going on and
um she's like nothing's on everything's
going to be okay and I'm like like
what's up Mom and I'm already I know I
know what he said I'm like mom he said
that I'll never walk again didn't he and
she's just like it's going to be okay
like I said Mom it's going to be okay I
will walk again I will walk again that's
faith
well a nurse came in uh the neurosurgeon
came in and they were like we're going
to perform another surgery after that
surgery I was able to drag my foot so
the left side of my body is what took
all the damage um but I was able to drag
my foot and so and then you'll fast
forward hospital stays
therapy um medicate all of it whatever
comes with that whole package $2
million yeah never paid never had to pay
a dime
wow right so you know when people are
like man praying to God for finances
like well he he you'll take care of it
you know saying he can totally take care
of he can work that out yeah he'll work
that out how did it happen What who paid
for it the state of California covered
the whole thing why oh you ask Jesus it
just happened they just they just did
they never they never came for me it was
never something that was on my they
never asked for anything and I'm telling
you I was doing like four years of pain
medication I was doing like a a year of
physical therapy I mean my physical
therapy got to the point where like it's
good enough you're off and you're going
to go figure it out yourself kind of
thing so you want to ask a question yeah
I have couple of questions one I'm I'm
sitting here thinking that you said
prior you were a
bodybuilder yeah bodybuilder athlete
yeah bodybuilder athlete yeah and yet
you were doing all these things to your
body kind of didn't so oh probably help
I mean I guess it depends if you're on
roids or something I was on HGH so my
final 6 months of um That season of my
life I was on human but here's the thing
there was a part of me that gave the
image that everything that was was okay
there was a part of me that liked so
Fitness and strength training started
off as anger management for me that's
what it was for me but then when you
start getting compliments guys look up
to you cuz you look like a Greek god and
the ladies love you because you look
like a Greek god right you like that you
know it wasn't about taking care of your
body it was about no it wasn't it was
promoting self-image yeah and I'm sure a
little bit was taking care of my I mean
I enjoyed sport I enjoyed Fitness I
enjoyed that outlet that was something
that I totally enjoyed do you think part
of that
was given that you grew up in a rough
environment you're like I'll tell you
the moment nobody is going to do that to
me again my dad was a professional boxer
and the Marines okay um yeah so my dad
uh and I love him again
um I was in the living room one day and
I was a skinny kid and he walked up to
me and he poked me in the chest and
called me a chicken chest yeah and I
just couldn't have that right and that's
where the fitness and the heavy lifting
started and so that's that's pretty much
Where it All Began remember careful what
you tell your kids yeah be careful what
chest yeah that's why I'm really care
careful with my kids you know um I just
don't want them to have the same stuff
so then I'm thinking after after all
that's happen is happen you're you're
you're getting back on your feet and
you're on pain medication for four years
is this now like not a very good thing
for you to be on pain medication because
you're past history like yeah well so
it's again it's all about self
medication the thing that I learned in
popping pills and taking those drugs was
that it was never really for the
physical pain relief there was to a
certain degree but there was a certain
feeling some of them gave to me over
others and that's when I realized that
the whole pain medication thing for me
was like a huge hoax because I was
chasing a feeling so I was given five
different kind of pain medications and
some were supposed to be highly
addictive but it didn't give me the
feeling I wanted so it wasn't that
addictive the one that was very
addictive to me was Percocet because it
gave me that buzz that I liked but dude
I was on oxycotton man people take that
stuff to the Grave man but me it was
like no that's not the feeling I want so
no I don't need to go back to it and I
think in that stage I realized that a
lot of my drug addiction and and alcohol
it it was a lot of it was mental a lot
of it was a spiritual issue but it was
very very n the mental pain yeah was to
numb the mental pain and so for another
four years I was still popping pills
getting drunk you know as God is giving
me my life back and this is when I quit
drinking so wait a minute you're
dragging your foot at what point are you
walking um
probably a few months where I'm actually
with a decent stride it took me a long
time so you just kept trying and trying
and trying and exercising I just kept
moving yeah I kept moving I kept doing I
kept doing things that the therapist
told me not to do I'm kind of that dude
he not a doctor this is not doctor oh
yeah yeah don't I it it was just
resilience grit stubbornness Rebellion
you know I mean I was raised by a marine
like there's a different mindset and
even though like it seems like I'm hard
on my dad I love him and the story I
have about him is amazing but um there
was that Marine mindset that kept
showing up as I was getting better it's
like no one's going to do it for you son
you got to go do it yourself like he
applied things in my life that made
sense later in life it's just he didn't
deliver them well and he had his own
battles and demons right same with me
and so it's really hard it was hard to
receive the messages now I look back and
I'm like dude you gave me a lot of
valuable stuff but at the time it's like
dude why so why you picking on me all
the time you know my dad was a marine
and it was always like that he told me
once he's like you may not go into the
room Marine Corps but I'm going to raise
you like
onee so okay dud oh my goodness dude I
would be laying in bed on a Saturday
morning and my dad would come in with
his whistle and he started say it's time
to get up it's time to get up it's time
to get up in the morning he take me down
to the the junior college run on the
track oh my do push-ups and pull-ups
yeah but look at me now yeah like that's
good you know training he he he planted
those seeds Maybe wasn't the best way to
go about it but but in my recovery I
just kept hearing my dad you know and
after my suicide attempt I also forgave
my my dad for my childhood my mom for my
childhood like I think that's a part of
um for me drug and alcohol addiction is
that self-medicating part and that
self-medicating comes from a lack of
forgiveness in your life so if you're
going to continue to point and blame
your parents for everything that you are
now and and and you know
um Embark in that victim mindset like Po
me Po me like cuz that's what I was
doing that's exactly what I was doing
when I realized that my mom and dad were
broken kids like me like I was I was
able to forgive them you know um they
were really young my mom was 17 when she
had me you know what I'm saying like my
dad I think was like 20 or 21 when he
met my mom and and you know they were
kids trying to figure it all out with
their own family history and Trauma and
generational stuff you know what I'm
saying and so you know for anyone that's
listening you know forgiving your
parents for the things that you went
through and there's also a difference
between forgiving people and also like
letting them fully back into your life
you know sometimes they're not healed
and they're not ready so you have to be
really mindful of that stuff as well
healthy boundaries very healthy
boundaries and that's something I had to
develop with both of my parents and
eventually you know I end up losing my
dad to to drugs um both of them um both
of them I'll get to the being delivered
and then I'll I'll share my two dad
stories with you guys because
forgiveness is everything um it truly
for us it's everything for the lord it's
everything right
um but I end up getting behind the wheel
of a car uh I was 9 months into dating
my wife and um New Girl new girl she was
not the one that would accused you she
got locked
up the first one no no no no no she
actually we'll go there a few years ago
she reached out to me saw my website and
reached out to me and she says I'm glad
you made it to the other side because I
haven't yet oo so I realized in that
moment that she was struggling with what
she had done yeah and um in that moment
I just prayed for her yeah you know Lord
sent a Godly Man to her let her know
that she's forgiven that it's okay that
she needs to heal and grow and move on
and that she needs a a godly man in her
life and she needs to raise children
like did you tell her that you forgave
her it was not a conversation I felt
like I was led to have in that moment
you know we had just moved out to
Colorado and um you know my son was
really young I just didn't want anything
interfering with my family makes sense I
didn't want to open up that door but I
also know the power of prayer and I I
hope that someone in her life came along
yeah and said something hey you need to
let that go he's doing fine like and if
you read my stuff it's like I love Jesus
you know what I'm saying like he found
the way right he found the way and now
it's your turn it's your turn to find
the way so so you were in the car this
is with your wife no she wasn't so so um
I got really into to BU body building
Again Fitness was kind of a God to me it
was an idol and um and I got hurt I got
a hernia and poor me poor Rob oh I can't
work out for a few weeks right not
taking in consideration everything I've
already been through I'm grateful to be
in this moment of being healthy and fit
right so I decided to pout and get drunk
and get behind the wheel of her car and
um I ran into a house ran from from the
scene of a crime fell into a creek then
hid under a home and um while I was
hiding under that home um I was like
Lord here we are again you know here we
are again and and he's like Rob right
right right right but what he did was so
beautiful so I gave you the story of how
he showed up and broke through the pain
medication when I was in the hospital I
mean God is powerful he can break
through all that stuff I'm drunk
underneath this house and I'm asking God
to bail me out of this situation I'm
like if you want me to marry Alyssa done
right whatever you want from me done I'm
just asking you to bail me but you don't
have to because I deserve the
consequences to my choices right and all
of a sudden it was like this movie
started to play before my eyes and over
the last four years the mercy the grace
the favor the forgiveness
the patience everything that he was just
in the last four years of me
rehabilitating I was told I was never
going to walk again you know I had all
these crazy bills like and he's showing
me I've given you your life back
everything and in that moment my heart I
felt my heart twist in my
chest and I realized how much he loved
me and
um I repented for my
Behavior and the spirit of addiction
left me I felt this heaviness leave me
and that's when I knew that addiction
was a very spiritual spiritual battle
and that was January 8th of 2013 and I
have not been to drugs and alcohol since
no am that's awesome no desire nothing
like that but that was through true
repentance but now from this point on
it's
like how do I give this life and this
love that you've given to me to other
people you know and that's through my
marriage and through raising my kids and
the nonprofit and the work that I do you
know going out in the community and just
being the light that people need and so
I made it um my responsibility to do his
work through me um because I want to see
people delivered from drug and alcohol
addiction Mental Health Health broken
relationships that's another thing like
I'm here today my son my oldest son so I
had a son from when I was 21 years old
crazy I was engaged went and hooked up
with some chick cuz that's what you do
right when you're a hot mess like me and
I got her pregnant and had a kid and um
he lives 11 minutes from Mikey it's
crazy so it's crazy because of how God
has made this happen and I'll tell you
this I'm very grateful for being here
today because I've watched this channel
for eight
and I've I told the Lord I want to be on
that show one day because I love the
work you guys do it's full circle I love
testimonies I was searching testimonies
of especially addiction and things like
that and I saw this guy's testimony on
the 700 Club on the internet I was like
dude that guy's got a great testimony
he'd be cool to be on the show and then
next thing I know I see him on Alex's
Channel and just be blessed mhm and he's
watching little light yeah like what are
the odds that I'm watching him he's
watching us yeah and then we build a
friendship and didn't know each other
never met each other for years yeah and
then finally I got to
go uh share my testimony at your program
he's got a a rehabilitation program
thing going on yeah my buddy and I we do
like do this thing where we invite
people that have been through trauma and
they're in their recovery so that they
can share their stories with the hopes
that somebody sitting in that room hears
thems in that story yeah you know and
starts working toward because the thing
that I believe is that a lot of us walk
with Christ but there's certain areas in
our life that we haven't handed over to
him or that we just don't understand or
that the enemy uses to bog us down so
hopefully by especially men being
transparent about the things that have
happened to them because I again a lot
of hard topics right um that another man
can hear or woman could hear themsel and
someone's story and saying well if they
made it on the other side you know
there's hope for me too so we do so
we're both wearing these shirts what's
this rise as lions rise as lions um yeah
so it's actually a playoff of resurrect
sorry
resurrect like Christ lion lion of Judah
so so rise as lions was really born as a
form of Resurrection restoration amen
was the whole drive and you know Jesus
being at the center of it all and so and
then I run recovery softball teams
called the recovery Rebels cool um it's
the the r that we use as the rough
riters r um I was a big fan of DMX
growing up well and then I would see I
don't know if you've ever seen his last
video oh yeah where he was like praying
and preaching and and I I relate to him
in the sense of feeling isolated getting
involved in drugs and alcohol feeling so
separated from everything else and he
was part of a music industry that
basically blackballed him because he
took a stand for it now did he every do
everything righteously no but you know
you could tell somewhere in there that
he was seeking for truth and that he
loved Jesus right and so the recovery
Rebels was a playoff of of rough writers
and then lrae had an album called
Rebel um and in a song he talks about
how Jesus went against the culture right
I mean
well that's where the rebel came from
the recovery Rebel so in recovery and I
think this has a large part to do with
12 step programs AA and a is that um
there's a stigma where we've been
labeled and been given a certain
identity um due to our our substance
abuse right if you're going to go around
telling people that they have a disease
well then you're tarnishing them and
that's almost a hopeless situation right
and that's not how I roll like we have
hope in Christ you know who the sun sets
free is free indeed amen I don't like
that either I don't go around saying I'm
a I'm a 11 years recovering addict yeah
no I'm set free I'm set free just like
you instantly I surrendered and God took
it yeah and never went back and so I
struggled and and then you know I think
at some point I I would really encourage
you guys to do a deep study on Bill
Wilson and that whole program and
everything that attached to it and
because there's a lot of Christians um
in those programs that believe that it's
a Christian program yeah and never once
does the big book talk about Jesus not
once so it's not Christian and also
there's some pretty deep ties to Bill
Wilson and Alistair Crowley um there's a
poem in his book that is related very
similar to one of the poems that Crowley
wrote in one of his books as well and I
read it years ago um and so I think you
know I would encourage you guys to try
to pack that situation and and because
there's people listening right now that
are believers they love Jesus they
need right now they feel as if they need
a 12-step program and and what I will
say about the 12ep program just like
I'll say about Crossfit because I'm not
100% into that either is that it
provides a a community it provides
support it provides uh structure yeah it
forces you to look inside mhhm which I
think is all valuable stuff but we also
know how they how sneaky the enemy is
right whatever he can get you to stay
attached to and I know that my early
stages in my recovery going to those AA
meetings I I I couldn't I couldn't call
myself an addict I knew that God had
delivered me amen um I I knew that I
never had a disease because I knew that
I was consciously making a decision to
self-medicate you know that was my
decision that was my I take that what I
take accountability for was my choices
those are my choices um and so I know
that there are people listening that are
struggling with all that um but there is
freedom outside of that I remember when
I walked away from AA all all your
friends from AA were no longer my
friends because I never I didn't part of
the club I'm not part of the club
anymore I'm not willing to go along with
it one of my my first year sober I was
invited to an AA meeting and they asked
me how I'd done it up to that point and
I'm talking about jesuso I'm like ah
Jesus saved me you know and I got pulled
aside and I was told that I wasn't
allowed to talk about Jesus in an AA
meeting that's that's crazy and it took
place in a church what wow yeah see we
found the one step program yeah yeah
Christ is the I call I call it
Footprints yeah it's the footprints
right he just he you he just walked it
out with me you know and and that's the
program you have an amazing story set
free from addiction started this
Ministry where you're helping addicts
through uh exercising and using other
things good positive things instead of
drugs you've been on the news multiple
times about it where do people find this
information how if they're struggling
they want to get Freedom they want some
Community how can they find you or some
other something that you recommend well
I would just Rises lions.org you know um
this is what I've always told people too
is that a lot of times we can't walk
into the church and talk about this
stuff a lot of churches either aren't
equipped or they're just not ready to
talk about these things yeah um I think
that's one of my struggles with the
church but that's a whole different
episode right there
um I know that a lot of times you can't
talk to friends or family members um I
know that there's been times where I've
didn't order a drink at a restaurant and
it was like oh you don't drink what's
wrong with you you know kind of kind of
thing so I understand that that shaming
and um that kind of stuff happen so you
know just reach out to me and if you
want to have a conversation if you need
some prayer like I'm there for you you
know um I will help guide you but I will
tell you this I've learned more about
going off on my own digging deep
spending time with the Lord researching
myself instead of allowing others to
formulate my belief systems for me um
yes so reach out to me Rises lines.org
amen like how you are you know I
pointing out that one of the things you
know the 12ep programs do is they they
kind of keep you identifying with your
addiction and over and over again in the
Bible when Paul's writing letters to the
churches he calls them saints multiple
times in in Ephesians he's calling them
saints but this is a church that was
involved in it says in one in chapter
six you know it talks about we're not
fighting
uh a physical War we're fighting a
spiritual war right 6 verse2 and how
they were once in darkness but now
they're the children of the light and
you look at the book of Acts and you see
how this church was involved in
Witchcraft and sorcery and all but he
doesn't call them that yeah he says
you're the Saints yes you were washed
right so walk as children of the light
don't don't keep
yourself here any longer I think are you
talking about First Corinthians 6
because right here it says no nor
thieves nor Covetous nor drunkards like
drunkard we we're drunkards that's what
we were we're not alcoholics we're at
the end of the day we're drunkers right
nor revilers nor extortioners shall
inherit the kingdom of God and such were
some of you like you're no longer that
drunker you don't have to go through
life saying I am an addict you're set
free you know you know the challenging
part uh is that what I've seen in almost
like
more than a decade of sobriety and
working with people that are a part of
the group
and
it's a lot of us we have codependent
Behavior yeah and what we're doing is
we're trading one thing for another and
I know that you know I traded you know
Fitness became my idol as well so that
was one of my things but what happens as
far as the group is concerned is that
that becomes their new drug and alcohol
yeah MH you know well those places every
time I see an AA meeting everybody's
outside chain smoking and drinking
caffeinated coffee like well they like
they're celebrating with cake and
cookies right which don't give I
love love cake and cookies but but
here's the thing you know it's a be it's
the same behavior yeah right you've just
given up one substance or one modality
of
self-medication for another and and that
was another thing I struggled with like
I remember showing up up to one of those
events and there was a guy who was like
30 years sober and he's like well if I
didn't come today you know I'd be at the
bar and no way yeah and and then he's
talking about like how such and such is
such a this word and a that word and you
know you hear all this stuff and and
even before I knew the Lord I looked at
that
situation um because I had to go to AA
when I was getting in trouble M um yeah
and I just listened to that and I said
bro there your problem's not alcohol you
have a heart issue man likees you have
you have much well I needed Jesus at
that time too when I was making this
assessment but it was like you know
there was much deeper things in your
life that need to be addressed and the
alcohol was never the issue but if you
have to keep coming to that that's not
Freedom that's bondage it is but they
but they may not see that right they may
not see that because what they do like
what they do like is the
that they develop and all that the and
and again I get that and that's why a
lot of people won't walk away from
certain churches cuz not all churches
get pastors either no matter what is
being preached from the pulpit because
of the the relationships that are being
developed there as well and a lot of
it's just a fear right you know a fear
of loss if they walk away but this is
what I've learned about love no matter
what I do if someone loves me they're
going to be there amen you know whether
or not we believe in the same theology
or or the same modality of recovery like
I'm not going to knock you for any of
those things I'm going to love on you
because if my truth is the truth I'm
going to walk in that truth and if
you're drawn to that truth yeah let's
make it your truth you know what I'm
saying that's right you know I'd rather
walk it out than brow be brow beat
people with it so right right yeah the
Bible says if the sun makes you free
you'll be free
indeed I came up in a church when I
first got saved after my suicide attempt
where the worship Pastor groomed me and
then he tried to sexually assault me he
moved me into his
house um bonus footage guys um he then
kicked me out because I wouldn't give
into his
ways
um the church knew about his behavior
but protected him
anyway the man had three
houses you know uh they make a church
pastor probably mega church very very
very compromised Church wow but I I I
just felt led to say something because
there's people out there right now that
are also struggling with church hurt I
know that a lot of people have
put the church became God to them God is
God you know the reason I didn't let
that stuff impact me like that was
because I had a relationship with Jesus
and and not so much about the people in
the church right and so um and I have
friends that got abused by the same man
that completely walked away from god wow
you know so if that is you um I
encourage you to go back to Christ
because that's not the heart of Christ
that's right yeah no thank you for
sharing that and making that clear
that's
definitely something we have to uh think
about consider we through yeah Jesus is
the way amen so follow Jesus Bible says
but of the people in the end they follow
the lamb wherever he goes and that's
Christ so thank you all for watching we
will list some resources below Rob's
website you know if you need to get in
touch with him you can reach out to him
that way and uh you know make sure you
comment on this episode let us know if
there's some elements here you can
identify with uh make sure you subscribe
to our Channel if this is your first
time here welcome you know definitely
subscribe you'll see more content like
this in the future and so make sure you
remember us we got all kinds of links
how to support us if you if you want
there's either giving through our
website or or through our t-shirt
Ministry there's all those all those
things so check those out thank you for
joining us and uh you know we hope you
join us next week on another episode of
LED live take care God
bless I'm sorry do we knew each other it
seems like maybe we've met before I
don't know this is uh it's awkward
though just as much for me as it is for
you I really wish I had a conversation
[Music]
starter oh hey oh what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try lightwear
[Music]
do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible questions in 5 minutes or
less check out these easy to understand
comprehensive videos talking about
everything from what happens when you
die to why does God allow suffering make
it your goal to deepen your relationship
with Christ this year and subs subscribe
to video bible study on YouTube to help
you along your journey
[Music]